[Music]
good evening everybody i'm jesse weber
and welcome to prime prime tonight
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile
and memorable true crime cases tonight
lies an affair and three shocking
murders
august 13 2018 frederick colorado
security footage captures shanann watts
a pregnant mother of two
returning home from a business trip
three days later
the dead bodies of shanann and her
four-year-old daughter bella
and three-year-old daughter celeste
would be found by police
from the outside shenan had an idyllic
life
she was married to chris watts a man she
described as the best thing that ever
happened to her
the young couple had two daughters and
were expecting their third child
so pink means that's just the test i
know they're just
the pink is gonna be girls i don't know
what we've since learned though
is that there were deep cracks in this
picture perfect family
thank you so much for coming out here
with me christopher
i'm having a wonderful time you mean a
lot to me
at the time of shanann's pregnancy
announcement chris was having an affair
with co-worker nicole
kessinger the relationship was
documented by
photos videos and racy pictures
the watts marriage would soon become
strained with texts revealing shanann
thought chris was being distant shanann
told a friend
she planned to speak to her husband
after her trip
instead later in the day shenan and her
daughters are reported missing
when a friend can't get a hold of her
sign of a mother and her two young
daughters who disappeared early monday
afternoon
34 year old shannon watts is 15 weeks
pregnant
chris says his wife and kids left while
he was at work
but never came back he even turns to the
media
pleading on tv for his family's safe
return
shenan bella celeste
if you're out there just just come back
like if somebody has her just
please bring her back but a neighbor's
surveillance video
tells a different story
[Music]
after failing a lie detector test and
police narrowing down their focus
chris you gotta tell us there's
something that happened to these baby
girls
look at them i know chris watts
admits to strangling shanann to death
but claims
she killed the kids his confession led
authorities to an oil work site
where shenan was buried in a shallow
grave and bella and celeste
discarded in oil tanks
watts would ultimately claim
responsibility for the murder of his
daughters
and plead guilty to nine charges
including
five counts of murder perhaps the most
inhumane and vicious crime
that i have handled out of the thousands
of cases that i have seen
he was sentenced to three consecutive
life terms in prison
unfortunately this is not the end of
this tragic tale
the public wouldn't learn more of the
story until later on
when watts sat down for a five-hour
interview
revealing new and disturbing details of
the killings
but the question still lurking in
people's minds
is why would a seemingly ordinary man
choose to brutally murder his wife and
children
in cold blood
say hi hello you don't want to say hi
let's start with one of the most
analyzed and controversial moments in
the case
when chris watts knowing full well what
he did speaks with denver 7 a local
media outlet the day
after his family goes missing and he
pleads
for their safe return right now i don't
even want to just like
throw anything out there like i hope
that she's somewhere safe right now
and with the kids but i mean
could she event because she just taken
off i don't know but if
somebody has her and they're not safe
like i want them back now
like that that that's what's in my like
if they're safe right now they're going
to come back
but if they're not safe right now that's
what that's the not knowing part like
if they're not safe last night i was had
every light in the house on
i was hoping that i would just get just
ran over by the kids running in the door
and just like barrel rushing me but it
didn't happen
and it was just a traumatic night trying
to be here
all right i want to bring in new york
law school professor and retired
new york city detective kirk burkhalter
and forensic scientist and
professor of forensic psychology
jennifer shen
kirk i want to start with you if you
were investigating this case and you see
him do that
what would be your thought there what
catches your eye about that interview
well certainly there are a couple of
things here that catch my eye one is the
use of the first person
singular so in other words his interview
with his responses he focused
a lot on himself how he felt what his
expectations uh would be that he would
like to see them come home
and didn't refer as often to
their well-being and safety so you could
think if a loved one is missing
that's what they would refer to also uh
the fact that he's alone
and somewhat devoid of emotion but the
first person singular
what he wanted what he wished what
that's what he focused on
that's really what struck me first a lot
of people are asking why
so jennifer explain to us the thought
process here of watts
why would someone in his position go on
tv and do this
well honestly it's because it's what's
expected when your
family goes missing then uh that is what
it's expected that you'll go to the
media you'll work with police he'll be
out there in front of the camera
saying please please please pleading to
bring them back and
you know i agree with the assessment
that he was very devoid of emotion
uh very first person oriented and uh you
just watch him and you just
absolutely don't believe anything he's
saying and i thought it was
very clear in this particular instance
well i want to move on to another
dramatic moment in this case and there
are a ton of them chris's initial
alibi was that shenan and the kids left
and disappeared
while he was at work but what chris
didn't realize
was that his neighbor's security camera
caught him loading his truck at 5
27 am he's the only one on tape leaving
that house so it disproves his story
i want you to watch carefully to chris's
reaction when his neighbor plays the
footage not just for him
but also a police officer that was there
as well
[Applause]
you think he looks nervous now here's
something interesting
when the neighbors shut down the replay
his tv went back to a normal broadcast
but i want you to look very carefully at
what appears on the screen and maybe
more importantly
what chris says
yeah i thought nothing nothing for the
rest of the day
no that's it
she's pregnant as well how far along
ah now you should mention that shenan
was pregnant investigators say that in
that 26 minute period he was loading the
truck up with shenan's body
and his two daughters jennifer back to
you what is your reaction
to his reaction well his reaction
i just sort of go i think it was like oh
my gosh i've been caught that's what
that looked like to me
and i think people forget that in this
day and age there are video cameras
everywhere your neighbors have them in
their doorbells they have them security
cameras they're
everywhere so i think that he was
experiencing of a moment of oh my gosh
i've been caught
and wow how stupid was that that i did
that in front of all my neighbors and
all their cameras it was
a really telling moment and the baby on
the screen oh my gosh
that's just that is heart-wrenching
heart-wrenching and again the neighbor
even said to the officer that he seemed
that chris was being very suspicious
let's move on to august 15. so at this
point the investigation is really
heating up and chris has told law
enforcement that
he doesn't know where his family is he
also denies having an affair
even though a search of his computer and
phone would show otherwise
but the investigators then asked chris
to come down to the police department
and he agrees to a polygraph test so
how'd he do
watch so it was completely clear
that you were not honest during the
testing and i think you already know
that
um he did not pass the polygraph test
okay okay
so now we need to talk about what
actually happened
i feel like you're probably ready to do
that
i didn't i didn't lie to you on that
polygraph i promise
chris
even though he's caught lying he's still
adamant that he doesn't know what
happened to his wife and kids
but when investigator tammy lee who you
just saw there asks if maybe shenan
hurt the girls chris then asked to speak
to his father ronnie
who was in the other room
[Music]
about that
talking about separation and everything
about pregnancy
i don't know like what else to say like
i freaked out
now in his first version or maybe it's
his second version he keeps changing him
he claims that
shenan killed bella and celeste and then
he strangled her to death
in retaliation he then says acting out
of fear
he disposed of the bodies at an oil work
site
where they would ultimately be found
i was so scared
okay there's a lot to break down kirk i
want to start with you what do you think
about the investigator's technique
technique here to get a confession out
of him particularly having his
dad come in that's very interesting so
you know here there's no expectation of
privacy in the
interview room using the father
especially if someone is uh i'll call
them an amateur with regards
to this type of crime it's going to be
very difficult
to lie look your father in the eye and
lie to your father
clearly they have a strong relationship
because the fall that did come to the
precinct
and wanted to get involved so i think
it's a useful technique
this coupled with already letting him
know that uh
he failed the polygraph and all these
other inconsistencies
i think the investigators probably saw
the father being the straw that would
break the camel's back here
and they had really pushed him to
confess and you wonder if he almost
wanted to confess then again what we do
know is he kind of picked on tammy
agent tammy lee's comment about did
shenan have something to do with this
and
jumped with that well later learned that
might not be the full story now jennifer
let me go to you
he failed this polygraph what can you
tell us about that
well i always find it fascinating that
people take polygraphs when they're
clearly guilty
polygraphs are set up to measure things
that you can't control like your you
know respiration
your heart rate your body temperature
and everything you can do to try to beat
a polygraph we've come up with a way to
keep you from
being able to do so so it is it always
surprises me
i i just think it's so incredibly stupid
to think that you can pass the polygraph
when you're clearly lying
so i thought this was an interesting
choice by him i thought it was
interesting they brought the father in
on the interview
i i've never seen that done and that was
that was i think really really effective
there's so many moments in this case
when you kind of see chris watts caught
like a deer in headlights he can't
believe he's in this position and yet he
tried to be
the innocent person always being there
always explaining always having an
answer for everything but as you can see
it doesn't really work out well for him
that interview ultimately led to his
arrest
but when we come back we have a lot to
get into we're going to get into exactly
the moment
when chris watts finally admitted that
he killed his kids
we'll be back
[Music]
every time i see pictures i don't know
how this could happen
being a dad was the best part of my life
i took it all away
chris watt's stories kept on changing
first it was he didn't know what
happened to his missing family
and then he said he killed his wife
shanann after
she smothered their daughters to death
and then ultimately
he would confess to murdering them all
now
three months after chris pled guilty to
his crimes and was sentenced to
multiple life terms in prison
investigators visited him to get more
details of the story
now the first thing he says he describes
strangling shenan to death
in a fit of rage after she confronted
him about cheating
i just wish i could have let go
did it seem like it was that long two to
four minutes
how long did it seem for you
almost kind of felt like it was i felt
like it was longer almost because it
felt like time was standing still
it's kind of like i just saw my life
just disappearing before my eyes but i
just like i couldn't let go
it was like somebody else like like if
you picture somebody else
around you holding your hands holding
you to keep you from
not not letting you then he says
his four-year-old daughter walked in
so what happened next
what happened what she said
[Music]
did she hear something is that what you
obviously nothing
okay
[Music]
and it only gets worse from there
because watts says
that he put his girls into the truck
placed their dead mother on the floor of
that vehicle
and drove them all out to an oil work
site he then proceeded to murder
his three-year-old daughter celeste
put the blanket over red
and that's how she passed it
[Music]
i put the blanket over here i didn't
want it no
and if that wasn't terrible enough
listen to what he claims bella said
as she watched the murder of her
i then sister down to bella tell me what
happened there
[Music]
she said what happened to cece
first yes it was the same thing
and the exact same thing that happened
to me is cc
did she ask you that okay so bella's
pretty smart
how does she sound like she has to get
rich so that
that software she always said
[Music]
and what exactly did she say
[Music]
she said is that good same thing that
happened to me as you see and then i
said
i ordered from what i said
okay i don't know if i just said yes
like a horrible person or if i just
put this put that blanket over her too
and did the same thing
same blanket same way okay
she said no daddy and that's the last
thing to say
and it doesn't really get worse than
that but unfortunately the story doesn't
end there
because while watts sits in prison he
wrote letters to a woman
named sharon cradle and she actually
published these letters in a book
and in these letters he goes into what
he was thinking let's pull some of them
up for example this is the first one
he writes of shanann's death i knew if i
took my hands off of her
she would still keep me from nikki they
asked me why she couldn't fight back
it's because she couldn't fight back her
eyes filled with blood
as she looked at me and she died i knew
she was gone
when she relieved herself here's another
one
he says august 12th when i finished
putting the girls to bed
i walked away and said that's the last
time i'm going to be tucking my babies
in
i knew what was going to happen that day
before
and i did nothing to stop it
kirk it seems again his stories are
changing once more
and that this wasn't a spur of the
moment killing but in fact it was
premeditated
that he planned to kill his family
because of another woman right to start
a new life is that how you see it
really uh so when i think of
premeditation i think of someone really
planning and thinking i am going to do
this so i do think
that at some point he made up his mind
to be predisposed
to kill his wife and possibly his
children however he just couldn't pull
the trigger
i think the day of the crime there was
something some reason
that he just decided that was the day he
was going to pull the trigger
but if you look at everything that
occurred this whole plan was
ill-conceived
um killing the wife before the children
or deciding how to do this not
necessarily knowing
you know poor planning so i think he was
predisposed to do this at some point
but i don't think it was a hardcore
premeditated plan
i don't know if i necessarily agree with
that but we will get a little bit more
into that
you know jennifer that the truth of the
matter is this is a horrific killing and
every killing is absolutely horrific but
here
strangling his wife to death smothering
his kids one by one having one witness
the death of the other
walk us through that walk us through
that level of violence because
this thankfully is something that we
never see a lot of and
and i've never quite heard a story quite
like this
well in my opinion a a crime like this
shows more than just a desire to get out
of a marriage or a desire to
unencumber yourself from your family it
shows
some level of rage and anger and hatred
and he must have worked himself into a
condition where he hated his family for
keeping him from
what he wanted because it is hard to
strangle someone to death
it is hard work and to do it while
looking in his wife's face
and then do the same thing to his little
innocent baby children it's just
he must have had such a level of hatred
in his heart
i don't know how he i don't know what
else to say about that
it had to it had to it's just one of the
most horrible things i've ever seen
and there are times we talk about when
someone can switch gears
they can stop what they're doing they
realize he had these moments where he
could have stopped what he was doing
and yet he didn't he kept going forward
and going forward and going forward
and tried to get away with it now kirk
as i said some
still believe that this is not the full
story i mean his stories just keep on
changing
do you believe that chris watts is going
to be providing more
details to come he's in prison he's got
a lot of time
he can give investigators the public his
fans i know there are people writing him
letters love letters
he can give them more details and it
becomes a question if we believe it or
not do you think we're going to hear
more about what happened
to shanann and the kids i think it's
quite
possible because he has so much time on
his hands
and as jennifer stated which i agree
wholeheartedly this was a crime
of rage and he is now in the process of
dealing with
so much guilt and having to look at
himself every day
i will go as far as to say if there is
more to this crime
we could certainly look forward to see
hearing about it at some point in time
maybe next week maybe next year
but at some point in time i think he'll
come out and jennifer i'll give you
about 30 seconds our investigators still
want to know more answers here
well i mean it's always interesting when
you see a crime like this of a person
who seems very normal
family life and then he does something
so outrageously
off the charts violent and and terrible
and so there is that interest in
in doing research to figure out how they
might have seen those signs
and look at the end of the day this is
something one of those cases that
happened
in one part of the country but everybody
knew about it and there's a reason for
it
it took people's hearts it took people's
attention and trying to make
sense of what actually happened is what
it's all about because again to have an
ordinary man
just ruin his entire life and kill his
entire family
i don't know and the truth is we may
never get a full answer as to why chris
watts murdered his wife and kids but
what i do know
is that shenan bella and celeste will
never be forgotten
that's all we have for you on prime
crime tonight give us your comments on
chris watts on twitter and facebook with
the hashtag primecrimetonight
thank you for joining us and until next
time be safe
[Music]
you